[Musica]
io sono stata chiamata qui per parlare
di politiche strategie per la
valorizzazione del territorio ma in
realtà la vera ragione per cui sono qui
e dare un senso a questa frase non è mia
ma la porto dietro nel lavoro che faccio
da quando ho iniziato giordano bruno
afferma non è la materia che crea il
pensiero ma il pensiero che crea la
materia solo filosofia
oggi vedremo che forse non è così perché
in realtà
andiamo a capire attraverso degli esempi
e attraverso un metodo per quale ragione
dovremmo sempre e solo partire quando
creiamo modelli di business dall'analisi
delle risorse materiali e quindi la
materia per capire se possiamo
avventurarci in un percorso in un
viaggio tutto da fare tutto da
cominciare nel nostro caso invece
partiamo al contrario partiamo dal
pensiero quindi partiamo dall uomo
e nel farlo la prima questione che
voglio affrontare con voi e che cosa
vuol dire problema in realtà quello lì è
un omino virtuale ovviamente potete
identificarvi in quel in quel soggetto
senza volto seduto su un punto
interrogativo
questo è l'atteggiamento che abbiamo
spesso nei confronti dei problemi della
nostra vita quotidiana ci sediamo ci
concentriamo sul problema e lo viviamo
così profondamente che non vediamo
nient'altro che il problema quello il
momento in cui difficilmente riusciamo a
trovare una soluzione
poi c'è l'altro atteggiamento ovvero
questo il cosiddetto punto di distanza
quando affrontiamo una situazione
creando un distacco da quella situazione
riusciamo a vedere non solo quel piccolo
pallino che il problema ma riusciamo ad
inquadrarlo nel quadro generale
nel contesto in cui si colloca che un
contesto fatto di cose problematiche
appunto ma anche di aspetti positivi
quello che vorrei affrontare oggi con
voi è la possibilità di abolire il
concetto di problema e aprire
completamente un'altra dimensione che è
quella dell'opportunità noi siamo
abituati a ragionare per problemi
ragioniamo per problemi perché andiamo
alla ricerca di soluzioni quando a volte
basta guardare quello stesso elemento
che chiamiamo problema come opportunità
e per farvi capire che cosa vuol dire
questo
quando ho deciso di avviare questa
attività di dico living in realtà io
avevo un problema da affrontare è questo
problema era dovuto e dettato da una
casa una casa vuota che aveva una una
cucina vuota una dimensione di attesa e
che io ho deciso di trasformare in una
casa piena perché perché ho guardato
quella casa come un'opportunità e non
più come un limite
la mia famiglia i miei genitori avevano
costruito investito tutto su un immobile
che per me figlia unica laureata in
filosofia che per tanti miei colleghi
era considerata qualche anno fa scienze
della disoccupazione si chiedevano che
cosa ne avrei fatto di questa di questo
problema in realtà tutto è cambiato
quando mentre ero in fuga negli stati
uniti ho cominciato a osservare la la
casa come un qualcosa di diverso dal
problema l'ho vista come il contenitore
di tutti i miei sogni quello era la
prima risorsa da cui partire per
coltivare condivisione di idee filosofia
appunto pensiero generativo capace di
creare con living non è altro che casa
come occasione di vita condivisa
nient'altro che questo persone che
vengono da tutto il mondo in questo
contesto rurale a montalto uffugo in
calabria stiamo parlando nella
provincia di cosenza in un posto che non
è mai stata una destinazione pure le
persone vengono per fare cosa per
confrontarsi e condividere progetti di
vita e di lavoro
quello che ho fatto attraverso gli studi
filosofici e stato capire perché queste
persone vengono da noi e ho trovato
quattro motivazioni fondamentali che
equivalgono a ciò che cerchiamo oggi
ispirazione ovvero qualcuno qualcosa che
sia in grado di motivarci all'azione
lentezza ovvero qualcosa che ci porti
fuori dalla caos della quotidianità e
che ci permetta di vivere il tempo e non
di sopravvivere al tempo cercano
autenticità
noi siamo fondamentalmente bipolari lo
sappiamo noi viviamo un reale e poi
viviamo un io virtuale che quello dei
social solo che quello dei social e
continuamente sottoposto al giudizio ed
e giudicante quindi è in un circolo
vizioso di apparenza quello reale trova
spazio qui in dei contesti a social ma
sociali come quelli che si creano
all'interno di questo spazio
infine l'ultimo motivo per cui le
persone vengono da noi è la necessità di
connessioni connessioni umane
connessioni professionali connessioni
che permettono di trovare un simile
oppure ritrovare qualcuno che ne sa
anche più di noi e può insegnarci
qualcosa che cosa succede quando i
nostri parametri cambiano
succede che ci mettiamo in una
dimensione prima di tutto di ascolto ma
un ascolto che non è quello a cui siamo
abituati un ascolto che si chiama
generativo e quando parliamo di ascolto
ci rivolgiamo verso due dimensioni verso
noi stessi quindi un ascolto interiore e
ci chiediamo chi sono che cosa so fare
che cosa voglio fare domanda
difficilissima ma dopo aver fatto questo
per passare dall'ecosistema
all'ecosistema
dobbiamo mettere a confronto le risposte
che ci diamo su noi stessi con quelle
come il contesto che mi circonda che
tipo di risorse a ma soprattutto io che
il ruolo assumo all'interno di quel
contesto
questa teoria dell'ascolto in realtà è
la base fondamentale di un metodo un
metodo internazionale molto conosciuto
creato da otto charmer fondatore del
presenze ying istituto delle m di boston
la teoria o nel nostro modo di generare
materia
noi affrontiamo una un passiamo
dall'ascolto che quello che abbiamo
visto adesso all'osservazione al sentire
ovvero devo capire come il contesto che
mi circonda mi soffoca
oppure mi stimola rispetto al chi sono
io quando sono arrivato in fondo ho
messo da parte i pregiudizi e gli
stereotipi la storia che mi apparteneva
fino a ieri la storia dei miei luoghi e
ho cominciato a risalire verso un futuro
emergente e questo futuro emergente
noi lo abbiamo testato su un caso
specifico stiamo parlando di vaccarizzo
di montalto uffugo cioè una frazione del
mio comune 500 abitanti una sola
attività produttiva ovviamente in fase
di spopolamento e poi in calabria che
diciamo vive un caso di non esistenza
non perde come per il molise per cui
sono dei casi in cui se ne sente parlare
solo in termini negativi in questo borgo
abbiamo riunito la comunità per
affrontare l'abbattimento di queste
quattro parole chiave cinismo che cos'è
il cinismo qualcuno di voi viene vi dice
sai che si potrebbe costruire
l'auditorium più grande d'italia a
campobasso e qualcun altro vi risponde
ma non siamo mica a milano
siamo solo a campobasso ecco quello è il
cinismo
poi c'è la paura molto più facile leggo
e quindi ciò che impedisce l'eco sistema
e poi la teoria 8 charmer ci dice che la
sua teoria deve essere abbattuta in
virtù di cosa dell'avanzamento del
prototipo ovvero l'azione costante la
teoria da sola non riesce a generare
cambiamento dopo aver fatto questo
passaggio
abbiamo individuato e coinvolto gli
stakeholder della comunità noi viviamo
tutti in una comunità cittadina di
quartiere di borgo di paese rurale ma
viviamo in una comunità e in ogni
comunità ci sono gli stakeholder ovvero
persone che svolgono un ruolo sociale
quelle persone hanno cominciato a capire
analizzando in che contesto vivevano ma
hanno cominciato a farlo autenticamente
individuando due cose i pieni ei vuoti
di solito noi quando facciamo un modello
di business
partiamo dai pieni cioè tutto quello che
rappresenta una risorsa immediatamente
utilizzabile per produrre qualcosa in
questo caso invece ci si concentra sui
vuoti
ovvero non ci sono trasporti non ci sono
servizi non ci sono attività beh tutto
quello che non c'è la mancanza genera un
opportunità da cogliere
dopo aver fatto questo ci siamo
trasformati in un teatro il 4 di mapping
e la vera genialità di questa teoria la
comunità diventa parte di uno spettacolo
teatrale dove ognuno non in persona se
stesso ma in persona il suo vicino di
casa
la persona che fino a un momento prima
aveva colpevolizzato per qualcosa che
adesso è costretto a capire a
comprendere ad assorbire su di sé come
una persona che gli può essere di
supporto alla fine di tutto questo
abbiamo tirato fuori quattro modelli di
questo borgo in borgo dove fino a un
secondo prima la frase leitmotif era qui
non c'è
niente ne sono venuti fuori 4 schemi di
questa di questa realtà e siamo passati
all'azione
o meglio alla co creazione ad oggi in
meno di un anno
la comunità è diventata impresa 55 soci
e ha scelto il come costituirsi ovvero
cooperativa di comunità ha fatto un
crowdfunding che meno di 40 giorni ha
raccolto 7 mila euro fuori dal borgo
quindi è uscita dai confini geografici
ed arrivata ben oltre ha deciso di
riaprire una bottega all'interno del
borgo ha deciso di formarsi per riuscire
ad essere d'esempio per altri borghi
d'italia che hanno bisogno di capire
come ripopolarsi allora la fine di tutto
questo il coli ving è uno strumento da
lì è partito tutto è uno strumento ed è
anche un'attività la valorizzazione del
territorio è una conseguenza ma ciò su
cui ci dobbiamo veramente focalizzare e
la nostra filosofia quella che riusciamo
a coltivare come pensiero autentico come
capacità di avere una visione che
possibilmente sia coerente con quella
che è la visione del nostro territorio
allora forse la divergenza non è
necessario avere un pensiero divergente
a volte basta semplicemente pensare
veramente grazie
[Applauso]